I gotta tell you though when I was on in
Detroit I wished I could be on WRI F
what a great legendary radio station
they had a guy on an afternoon Drive
called Arthur pan Hollow and you know
what he would do I got on the air the
guy had a beautiful voice and he get on
the air and let's say you play like um
you know Bob Seger or something they
played a lot of Bob Seger in Detroit and
they didn't he'd get on and go baby
just like that that was his word baby
baby I'm like baby the [ __ ] is this well
I was in laughing after I saw those
ratings this [ __ ] had everybody
just some saying baby this is a serpent
Hollow baby baby and you'd wait for him
to say baby they loved it in Detroit
here's some Bob Seger baby I like it but
I should have come up with some kind of
catch word but I didn't have one I
didn't have a thing
hey now but it's not even mine no you
yeah I ripped that off you know Hank
this isn't easy for me but would you
mind not doing it on the show anymore
hey no there you just said it again and
you know I asked you not to say it
I can't say it offstage it doesn't even
exist you say now in a sentence Hank you
say and of course my sidekick Hank and
of course my sidekick Hank you know Hank
that's a sentence I'm gonna let's come
up with something but realizing for
turnin eyes about fraternity for turnin
eyes and baby you were next to Shirley
in the urinal and you shook his [ __ ] I
went over and just gave me like a little
quick squeeze just like you know like
return izing for turnin izing you get it
right return a knife to work work
through it let's hear how your brain
works
Frette was like with frat brothers [ __ ]
around return arising return arising for
turnin izing even Eric the actor had bye
for now
alright Eric well thank you and I'm
sorry about the McPhee upset last night
Dixie Chicks I the new song that they
got out I think is pretty good all right
Eric thank you bye for now right for now
new catchphrase right you know but he
abandoned it yeah didn't wouldn't do it
anymore I'd say Eric and you say bye for
now he's no well then I guess it's bye
for now
where's your catchphrase trash phrase
yes
ronnie has whoa whoa whoa stop the clock
out of anybody he has a bunch a streaks
he's got a streak that's right Ronnie
made Mother's Day sex tips take some
butter spread it all over your ass
shrieks let it slip a streaks spread it
all over your ass shrieks he should have
been a radio guy that could have been on
in Detroit Gary even has hello hello
hello hello after we broke up I took a
video camera I put on a tripod i
videotape myself you know cuz she
wouldn't talk to me hello hello she come
the teeth holy cow that girl head for
the hills
nobody's seen her and yeah crazy right
yeah yeah